- Subscribe.
You can probably tell
by my nondenominational
holiday sweater that
it's the holiday season
and that means time to decorate
to feel like you're a part of something.
This video's all about DIY ornaments
and holiday decorations that you can use
to decorate your home or give as gifts
to your friends and enemies.
Guess what I am?
An idiot.
So here are some of my
holiday ornament DIY
and some other holiday...
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] For this first
DIY you're going to need a pen,
some happy and unflattering
photos of your friends,
some scissors, some glue,
some cardboard you should
have recycled weeks ago,
and string or pipe cleaners.
So the first thing you
want to do is print out
one happy and one way more
judgmental looking photo
of a friend of yours.
Then you're going to want
to remember that you forgot
to mention that you also need some sort of
circular shaped thing to
trace for this project
and feel like a (bleep) idiot.
Then you're going to
trace the circular object
onto your cardboard.
You want to make two circles.
Then you're going to cut out
those circles using scissors
and you're going to get so bored.
This is so boring and difficult
and why is it happening to you always.
Then you're going to take the happy
and unflattering/judgmental
photo of your friend
and trace your circular cardboard shapes
onto the face of each one.
Then you're going to
use your scissors again
to cut them out and it's going
to be so boring for a second,
but you carry your boredom
cause you're (bleep) adorable.
Pose.
Once you're done cutting
the circular shapes
out of your friend's photos don't forget
that you want the world to think
that you are environmentally conscious
so recycle those photos
into like cute earrings
or even, I don't know, a bikini.
Oh my God.
Then we're going to use our
glue once we get it open
and oh my God this glue is so offensive.
We're going to take our glue
stick and just glue the photos
of our friend's faces
onto each side of one
circular piece of cardboard.
And there you have it,
what I call a friend coin.
When you need advice about something
and your friend isn't
there to give you their's,
you can just flip your friend coin
and make your decision from there.
Should I continue in my
lifelong pursuit to marry Sting?
My friend coin says yes.
Friend coins make great gifts.
They make even greater
ornaments for your tree.
Just poke a hole into...
Oh my God, offensive.
Poke a hole into the
top of your friend coin
and string a string through it.
I don't have string so I have to use
this fucking pipe cleaner.
And then just put it on your tree.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, you are so great.
(upbeat music)
For this next ornament
DIY you're going to need
some clear spherical ornaments.
I got these from Michael's.
A dead plant from your house,
preferably a succulent, and some mints.
So the first thing you're going to do
is take one of your
clear sphere ornaments.
Again, I got these from Michael's.
Oh my God, offensive.
Then you're going to do the ornament
what you did spring break 1999,
pop the top off
and then you're going to
take your dying succulent
and just ponder life for a second
and that there are some terribly
awful people in the world
and if they just had
any kind of compassion
for the rest of humanity
and that we're all in this,
you know, fucking shit storm together
maybe we could all kind of deal with life
in such a more pleasant way and it's...
Ha, ha, ha just kidding.
Your cute pose and repress.
Then you're going to
take your dead succulent
and just kind of take the
dirt and shove it into
your ornament and like spring break 1999
just continue shoving
until there you have,
oh my God, the cutest
terrarium ornament ever.
Eat my dick Pinterest.
Oh my God, look at it.
On second thought eat a
thousand dicks Pinterest.
For this last ornament DIY,
we're going to take again
one of our spherical ornaments
and some mints, not sponsored,
and we are going to just fill
the ornaments with mints.
And there you have it.
You have an orna mint.
Oh my God.
Oh my (bleep) God.
Oh my God,
we are so alone.
(upbeat music)
Here are some other quick holiday tips.
Just take some battery operated candles
and then turn them on
or take a candle and light it
or take a Santa hat.
Oh my God.
(upbeat music)
- Well there you go.
There are my holiday tips and tricks
and DIYs for your holiday.
I don't know.
Just look at that.
Wow.